today is an exciting day I've waited for this moment basically my whole life
your whole life
my my whole life
my whole life my whole life before right
no no
my whole life for a Little House in the Prairie
Silver Dollar City crossover
and that is what's happening today
we got that we got that today
so I guess that's a lifetime wait paid off
good for you Jen
I'm about to head out and I'm about to give Dean Butler
aka Manly his first Silver Dollar City experience
so here we go everybody
everybody buckle up cause it's gonna be a roller coaster ride
see the massive tree for the first time
so this is about to be a really cool moment
so let's see what the thoughts are on this huge tree
oh yes the massive Christmas tree
the lights at five we have to see that cause I love Christmas trees
the gates have opened and we're headed to Time Traveller
to give Dean his first experience of Time Traveller
Time Traveler yeah
hopefully you don't get sick
the front row seat of Time Traveler
it spins while it goes forward
yeah I'm definitely warmer than I was when I got on
now we're headed to powder keg
okay we're gonna try to get all of these rides in before it gets dark
while the park is just newly open
so we don't have to wait in super long lines okay
this is me after powder keg
should we do the barn swing and just swing up and down
there's a little more G force
but there's no does it
does it invert no
I looked over he was crying on Powder keg
and then I said no
my eyes were watering yeah yeah yeah
his eyes were watering Dean watched how the giant barn swing works
and he's decided that he's willing to ride it with us
so we are embarking on riding the giant barn swing
and we'll see how this goes
this is what I look like after the barn door
oh my god
we just got done with the Christmas Carol
and it was great and now it's dark outside
and Dean's about to experience the magic of Silver Dollar City
Silver Dollar City at night
it looks beautiful as we exit the theater
we're headed to go get some apple dumplings
Dean has his salted caramel
yes salted caramel
vanilla swirl
very tasty
but he's looking for one of those massive mountain chocolate chip cookies
because we know that that's his favorite
so that's coming up around the corner
and I'm sure he'll be very happy at the end of all of this
and maybe even take a gift home for Katherine
which will be perfect so do you need a Coke
some kind of Coke ornament
it would be nice if they had a Diet Coke one
because that would be more your style yeah
somehow
goodbye bye